Romain: Julien ?
Julien ?
Oui... Pardon... Excuse-moi... Je réfléchissais !
Romain: Ah ! Mais tu réfléchis à quoi ?
A nous, à DTC... Tout ça !
Romain: Aaah ! Et alors ?
Et alors, oui, exactement...
DTC ça existe depuis déjà plus d'un an et demi
Alors c'est vrai, à l'échelle de l'histoire de l'humanité... C'est quoi? C'est un pet de scolopendre !
Mais vu de ma fenêtre, ça fait quand même un peu plus.
Genre... Je sais pas... Un pet de ragondin géant !?
En fait en vrai, pour vous donner une petite idée ça fait vingt mois, donc, à peu près, une centaine de vidéos une trentaine de...
...millions de vues et puis surtout quatre cent mille abonnés : vous !
Et comme la fin de l'année approche...
Bah, le début de l'année suivante approche aussi... Du coup c'est le meilleur moment pour...
1) Faire un petit bilan
Et 2) Prendre des résolutions. bon c'est vrai c'est ma chaîne donc dans l'absolu je fais ce que je veux !
Mais on est quand même 400 000 !
Donc j'ai pas envie de faire les choses dans mon coin.
Alors je vais réfléchir à haute voix on va en parler un peu tous ensemble...
Ça va être un beau bordel. Et à la fin je déciderai pour la suite. En gros la question que je me pose...
Bah il y en a plusieurs. Sur la fréquence des vidéos d'abord.Des centaines de vidéos donc, une par semaine !
Sur des sujets... des fois légers, des fois plus sérieux... dans tous les cas ça représente plusieurs heures de travail de recherche, ...
... d'écriture, de tournage, etc.
Oui alors je sais ce que vous vous dites : plein de vidéos ça veut dire plein de vue donc ça veut dire...
!!! YOUTUBE MONEY !!!
Hé bah non! Pas du tout! Non! Non! Du coup... dans un premier temps...
Première annonce : Je vais espacer est un petit peu les vidéos sur DTC ! ...
... Le temps de me consacrer à un autre projet, qui a un lien avec DTC ...
... Mais dont je ne peux pas parler pour le moment ! La question c'est ensuite !?
Début 2018... Est-ce que je reviens à une vidéo par semaine? Une vidéo tous les 15 jours? Ou pas vraiment de rythme?
Je me pose la question !
Je vous pose la question!
Et puis il y a la question des formats ...
J'ai pas envie d'arrêter les formats actuels!
Ceux qui font l'identité de DTC : que ce soit les face cam, les tests, les Dans Son Corps ...
Le petit dernier qu'on a testé récemment et qui s'appelle la question que tout le monde se pose !
Mais j'ai un peu envie de me renouveler et tenter des trucs vraiment différents, des trucs un peu plus spontanés, des trucs un peu moins...
... écrits, sur le terrain, par exemple genre un peu comme les tests mais en plus léger et puis aussi de la fiction...
... genre des sketchs !
J'ai plein d'idées ! Et il y en a pas mal qui ont un lien avec la santé... donc ça peut se passer sur DTC... ou pas !
Je sais pas vraiment si ça a sa place ici. Donc, vous voyez, je me pose plein de questions...
... et je suis sûr que vous pouvez m'aider à y répondre et je suis sûr que vous vous posez aussi
plein de questions !
Alors ce que je vous propose c'est qu'on se retrouve tous ensemble pour réfléchir un petit peu à tout ça, et aussi juste pour tailler le bout de gras ...
... autour d'un live. Au moment où je tourne cette vidéo je n'ai pas encore décidé de la date et de l'heure de ce live !
Je vous annoncerai ça sur Twitter et sur la page Facebook de DTC. Donc n'hésitez pas à aller vous abonner, histoire d'être au courant ...
... le moment venu. En attendant de nous retrouver en live et discuter en veux tu en voilà ...
... bah vous connaissez la chanson ...
... mettez vous bien et surtout portez-vous bien !
GENERIQUE DE FIN
ABONNE-TOI !